c'est une vieille tradition et elle est
sacrée tous les astronautes qui s'envole
à bord d'une fusée russe viennent ici
sur la place rouge tous ensemble rendre
hommage et déposer des fleurs sur la
tombe du premier homme qui a voyagé dans
l'espace youri gagarine un héros
national
les mamans plein d'émotions c'est très
symbolique ainsi venus on fait juste
faire un petit pas de plus mais des
grands pas initiaux ce qui les ont faits
puis c'est aussi la conclusion de
plusieurs années d'entraînement car
c'est officiel aujourd'hui le décompte
est commencé pour le canadien david
saint jacques et ses coéquipiers
l'américaine ann mclean et le russe oleg
konan aime qu au terme d'une semaine
cruciale d'examen de simulation le trio
a reçu le feu vert pour décoller le 3
décembre prochain ce sera le premier vol
habité de la sioule depuis son décollage
raté au mois d'octobre qui a failli
coûter la vie à deux astronautes il y
aura toujours un risque dit sergueï clic
alors le numéro deux de l'agencé russe
roskosmos
mais ce risque est minutieusement
calculé après ce qui s'est passé au mois
d'octobre
ça nous a rappelé que les voyages
spatiaux c'est difficile et ça permet
seulement de se concentrer sur les
détails l'importance de la préparation
nous sommes prêts et puis c'est la fin
d'un long chemin ce pèlerinage au
kremlin avec sa femme aura été une des
dernières sorties publiques de david
saint jacques avant le décollage et on
se prépare doucement surtout à la
séparation de la famille a laissé la
terre deux m'ont dit que ce premier
sentiment qui nous habite à l'arrivée en
orbite se sentant que oui je suis
montréalais où ils sont québécois ou
canadiens ou chinois américaine mais je
le baril avant tout intérêt je
m'approche de ça il passera avec
l'équipage ses médecins
les deux prochaines semaines en
quarantaine dans un hôtel du kazakhstan
vous allez me donner des nouvelles
ouais on peut pas garder ça pour soi une
expérience comme ça je vais essayer
d'amener le plus de gens possible à bord
virtuellement
bon voyage si thammarat alter escaut
radio-canada moscou